thank you for joining us for this scene
at the academy for nightmare alley i'm
peter d'bruce chief film critic for
variety magazine i'd like to introduce
the team behind the film we have
guillermo del toro co-writer producer
and of course director of nightmare
alley bradley cooper actor producer
miles dale producer
dan lausten director of photography
louis cicara
costume designer
tamara deverell production design
now we'll look at a scene from the film
in which david stratharin's character
pete shows stanton carlisle his
mentalist act
are you okay
oh the poor woman she wanted to know
more
uh of course she did
what did you tell her now the truth we
missed a cue and i had to use a trick to
ease the crowd it's just a trick
it hurt
well it's good it's good that you did
that yeah
well
i gave her an amulet
i'm sorry i missed the cue i don't know
why you don't keep going for it
you never do a spook show no
no good comes out of the spook show is
it so bad to give her hope
there ain't hope if it's a lie stan
all right well what are those cards in
hmm material oh honey it ain't the same
thing no i even
run them over for myself and pete you
always get some kind of answer
i bought those for you in paris
who stayed at the ritz
held over four weeks uh
what they teach story
i wrote most of the word system on that
tour
that's where we perfected the act
didn't we george can you still do it
all right
stan
give zina uh an article in any article
please concentrate on this object i have
in my hand professor
what can you tell me
wristwatch
leather band
brass not gold
old
worn down
oh
but it's full of meaning
oh it wasn't yours originally was it
you took it i
you stole it didn't you
oh i see an older man
oh the boy hates
well
him
boy would love to be loved but he hates
that man he
all right
so
death
destiny we should have did
he thought that watch that was his pride
my father
was it now
no no no no that that's it that's it
that's it
that's uh
it's all there
now you see
each word has a number
and that number leads you to a different
word
bubble
and that xena feeds them to me
please concentrate on the object i have
in my hand professor please and object
21
emphasis on concentrate means that it is
old and worn down cheap
bubbles
what
you got to know how to read the mark
you know how they move talk
dress
people are desperate to tell you who
they are
desperate to be seen
ain't that the truth
what i love about this scene guillermo
is the way you're kind of playing with
the codes of film noir which of course
has affected all of your cinema until
now but this is the first real noir film
you're making uh how were you kind of
thinking about reinventing you know some
of those aesthetic
signatures for a color film
well when we started the process
dan and i were doing a film that was a
black and white color so to speak so the
contrast ratio and the style of lighting
was very much of
a film of that style sentence by
expressionism and classical studio
lighting and the realism
and
the creation of
a movie that was not
just a period
but it felt of the time were paramount
in our heads
dan uh i understand that uh guillermo
had wanted to
potentially shoot shape of water in
black and white so this is a
conversation that you guys have been
having for a while and this of course is
a movie where you've actually released a
black and white version though of course
the the theatrical version most of us
saw was color would you talk a little
bit about uh the kind of uh
translation of a black and white uh
language to color
yeah when we start to talk about first
of all you know we talked about shape of
water he wants to do that in black and
white and i was like wow but we didn't
have them and then we talked about this
one and we said we want to do a color
move there
you also have like deep blacks and a
very nice uh
highlight exposure for the for the key
light so you know so if we was later on
going into a black and white version we
have the possibilities to do that
uh tamara i'd i'd love to hear uh your
thoughts on the scene that we've just
looked at you know is typical i think of
the first half of the movie which if i
understand correctly was shot second and
that you first did the sort of uh you
know the big city high life uh
uh stuff but uh
the this is really the side that you
know feels more traditional noir i think
would you talk about you know we heard
of about the lowering ceilings but what
other touches you know were you kind of
incorporating uh into the into the set
that we've just seen in the scene
um i think once once we decided to lower
the ceilings and i mean that was a tough
decision i was actually running to lewis
saying how tall is bradley to make sure
that he fits
in the ceiling because it was literally
a few inches above bradley's head but we
um you know what was important to me was
to put texture on the ceiling because we
were going to see them so much um so i
was i was sort of focusing on a bit on
uh in zena's bungalow on we did a tongue
and groove which is traditional for the
period and in the back bathroom area
that you don't see in that scene we did
uh press tin again adding a lot of
texture and and and you know for me it's
it's giving each set a sense of history
so our amazing team of painters just you
know do many coats of paint so that you
you're you're not walking into fresh
space
um those are some of my considerations i
mean i just looking at that scene now i
love the way you know dan lit it and
brought you know brought those textures
up but also
at one point you know david is in the
shadow of i guess it's bradley's head
and
it gives it just lights his eyes and i
just when i when i just watched the
scene i was like that is so cool and
kind of ballsy to do that
so kudos always dan
dan let's go back to writing because you
know this is
evocative of film noir but i think
you're not copying it directly you're
kind of interpreting it and a good
example is the way that the characters
each uh but stanton carlisle bradley's
character in particular kind of sit in
pools of light and it sort of gives
their face certain shadows but if you
look at film noir it can often be like a
really harsh
white light pouring in and and then
everything else can kind of be bathed in
in black uh you're you're doing it
differently here would you talk a little
bit about uh the design
of the lights for this yeah when we
talked about blocking the scene you know
we once we knew we were shooting so wide
angle but when gamer blocked the scene
we talked a lot about the west with the
key light coming from our west with the
till that coming
and that was a little bit tricky because
the camera is moving so much and we see
most
out of the room all the time and he we
didn't want to front leg you know we
want to be sidelined or three-quarter
lives so you know bradley was a big part
of the gaffer team on this show because
he was always playing around for the
shadows a little bit and you know it was
a big big help of course and frank thank
you for that bradley but it's just you
know unique
to throw to you at this moment because
you really are having to do your
performance within all of these other
moving elements without the audience
being aware of the contributions of you
know the design the the
you know the cinematography etc what are
some of the sort of challenges that
posed to you in terms of i don't know uh
blocking uh
or uh you know sort of uh
positioning yourself in a way that is
above the performance and knowing kind
of like that you're part of this uh the
architecture of the scenes
well i mean the beauty about working
with all the artists on the zoom is that
you don't think about any of that
because a world is created for you that
you enter into and just utterly believe
um and that doesn't always happen you
know there's a part of your brain that
has to be used for the imagination of
what the space could be
but in in this film at every turn uh
none of that energy was necessary
because it was all done for the actors
so and that's a very unique experience
that i've never had before of of the
attention to detail and and and dan
brings up a great point you know often
the lighting was outside of the set
um which for an actor is heaven
um
and uh because of so many wonderful
lenses that they chose to use for this
film
um so yeah so the truth is my answer is
that it just made everything easy and
that's that's kind of uh what a gift
you know easy uh in terms of entering
into this the space from the moment i've
first met louis i mean his attention to
detail i cannot say enough about the
clothes that were stantons i mean and
the amount of times we went over that
tuxedo jacket
you know i mean
and there's something lewis just never
gave up to and same with the tamara and
dan like i'm tell i mean just we were
always searching for the best way to
execute always and no one ever gave up
and uh when when you have guillermo at
the helm who's gonna pivot if he has a
great idea to watch everybody just go
along and and give it their best to
accommodate that was inspiring
let's talk a little bit about uh the
costumes and i'm especially interested
in the kind of way that the movie is in
two halves because you know bradley's
character
traverses that where a lot of the others
are kind of existing in one half for the
other but you kind of have to reinvent
him and there's a jump in the middle too
so
talk a little bit about how you wanted
to sort of prepare the first half so
that the second half would uh present a
different version of uh of his arc
well specifically to the scene what i
love about this scene is that um the
characters have just come from the
carnival so it's all about peeling away
these these layers of the what people
see and then seeing what what we see
behind that so you know the pull away
shirt and xena's taking off her her
performance
dress um
so i love that about this scene in in
relationship to
stanton's character i think we we talked
about fit and and uh proportion from the
beginning of the movie to the end and
and what
was unfitted and a little loose at the
beginning obviously tons of texture um
we then moved into perfectly tailored
garments which of course uh thank you
bradley um you know yes we wanted to
make it as as good as we could
um
and uh and i think it i think it worked
out well but uh it really was about
impeccable uh fabrics textures
fit um
and um that
that arc was was remarkable again at the
end of the movie where where we just go
to a whole another level
the other thing i just want to start an
interrupt just present the other thing i
just want to say about lewis's work is
that also the form always followed the
function it was what was in that
suitcase that we saw stanton have when
he arrived at the carnival and you know
there could be definitely the
inclination like well this will be great
and then in this scene he's wearing this
you know but it was like okay how could
we how can we fit that suitcase to the
best of your ability in order to then
tell the story and i just to watch him
deal with that rubik's cube was pretty
incredible
for the level of uh of work and planning
that went into this i mean how does this
compare you you've worked with yama del
toro before
you know shape of water of course and uh
but uh you know just to clear the decks
for something this ambitious uh you know
what
what fights needed to be won
well it really isn't a fight it's more
of um uh
explanation of the vision uh
communicating the clarity of the vision
i mean this group we've all worked
together a lot so the beauty of the
shorthand
that we have uh is a great thing because
um
we know that guillermo's expectations
are high and i think our greatest fear
is to come up short um
so we all
knew kind of what we were doing and and
the thing about this group is that you
know guillermo really considers this to
be
for lack of a better word production
design is
tamara dan lewis shane and it's a
combination of those things there's
nothing
arbitrary there's no paint color or
wardrobe fabric that isn't uh
considerate of the lighting
or you know the other thing so when we
see in the garden you know stan and
grindel's dark
uh coats contrasting against the snow or
in the hotel room stan's robe
contrasting perfectly against the
wallpaper and those color palettes the
carnival color palette being different
from the buffalo color palette those
things uh i've never worked with a
director who's approached it with such
precision uh as guillermo and i learned
that um i mean originally on on mama and
then on the strain and then again on the
shape of water uh but really it felt
like it hit kind of a new
um
peak on this film and you know frankly
covid was very difficult for us in terms
of having to manage the film but it did
give us a lot of great opportunities we
were talking about the carnival we had
built the carnival in the spring of um
2020 and we were actually in a big rush
and so when we stopped it was nice um
that you know it got beaten up in the
rain and the wind and the sun and when
we got back to it in september it was
much more authentic it really saved the
scenic painters a lot of time doing
aging that only nature could do so um
you know there were there were some
great moments and there were some high
expectations and and and you know
personally i feel that this group really
uh achieved and and exceeded um in most
cases one thing i just want to add about
the carnival and what everybody was able
to create you know when you go into a
location sometimes you turn to your left
you think well wait that's the better
place to shoot rarely does that happen
on a set that's been built um but i
remember guillermo and dan when uh it
was the tenon one where stanton
originally was going to pitch the
electric chair to mali but molly's
tamara had created such an incredible
wagon in the path down remember and you
and garen was like no it's got to be
there he's got to come down we have to
we have to access all of this incredible
set design and production design that
wasn't in the movie and because of that
because of the attention to detail that
flexibility to be able to do that on a
set i mean i've i've never experienced
that where you're literally like wait
you know it's not only it's just
that was just one of the most exciting
things uh for me as a love a lover of
this art form that day and that that
that pivot was very exciting to be a
part of yeah
bradley are you learning things uh you
know for future times that you will be
directing from these experiences with
other directors directors like guillermo
and this incredible team
yeah i mean every every moment yeah
i mean
next time you make a film at a carnival
you'll build the whole thing out so you
can do it
now the carnival's been crushed i will
never step foot in another carnival
again
you can't beat it
you know i think that
what we
aspire to as directors is to inspire
and be inspired and this group did that
for me
you you all have done such incredible
work here i i appreciate that we had the
chance with this one scene to kind of
dig into some of the details but we
could talk about any two minutes of the
film
for 30 minutes or an hour at a time
thank you all for joining
congratulations on your nominations
and your work will stand the test of
time
thanks thank you very much thank you
thank you guys